we are here in the emirates
in dubai on my camel farm i'm actually
from germany it was never in my mind to
reading camelot it just came by chance
wherever i am in the world food is the
focal point of everything i do
my name is ching and i'm a chef and food
writer my taste journeys have taken me
all over the world in search of great
flavors and new recipes
finally it has brought me to dubai and i
can't wait to explore its rich and
varied food scene one bite at a time
i've come to meet ushi a camel breeder
has kept all the traditions of emirati
flavours alive year after year since
moving here from germany in 1988. nice
to have you here nice to meet you how
are you
thank you
what i saw that time especially the city
here in dubai already it was very
beautiful much different than to other
countries you cannot have a better place
as a woman than here emirati culture is
very respectful and very open-minded
first when i came as a tourist i love
the country i see i feel there is
something in the early days i met this
local family and i fell in love with the
family so the emirati culture is full of
love i feel like openness
what the family give to me
i give now to
the people from outside and i want to
give it to you thank you that's amazing
amazing thank you
many people have no chance to meet local
people and to know their real tradition
and that's why
i love to to being a host and people who
coming to me they keep me going and
going and going
i know he's hungry he's found the food
this is how the big screens this is also
our lane dates this is like uh dessert
to him
yeah yeah
forget the main course he's got a sweet
tooth yeah not getting too much
so their meat is really prized isn't it
yes it's the lowest cholesterol of any
kind of meat and also very low fat much
lower than cow
emirati families if they're not have
camel for racing or for competition they
will not sell it but they will have it
for the whole family i see you see you
can touch her nose how soft like pants
hello sweetheart oh she's gorgeous yeah
what i learned from ushi is that it's
about using very simple humble
ingredients but cooked with love each
with its different traditions to really
give you that bedouin and desert
experience
i just broke it i've just broken it
okay
[Music]
yeah
it's okay
oh it's hot
hot
that's really good
i think i'm hired
my earliest memory way of cooking
they're using different spices and
different repairing i eat my first goat
leg here
it needs two hours before you make the
fire ready and the preparation in
between and then two hours to cook it
this makes the difference
[Music]
the goat was amazing such a simple but
humble ritual it tasted so good i loved
every minute of it we have here la
hambush
camel meat in this spice is just simple
salt and black pepper
that is so good
the fact that people have been sitting
on in the desert for thousands of years
like this it's so beautiful i've had
such a magical day
yeah i hope so and you are a wonderful
guest oh thank you
ushi is the queen of the desert who
knows that her heart belongs here in
dubai
she is a true bedouin a free spirit and
she knows how to really deliver emirati
hospitality
[Music]
you